Oh, she's a lovely
woman It seems like it's okay to look at her She's
like a real tree now It's
okay if I'm here
Let's live together
Excuse me,
Nurjegyun Is that all the testimony?
no 4th place No need to ask more than this, come on and leave the
stage It's okay,
Rachel  You
've heard the testimonies of those people who gave you your verdict
Especially Danny is easy to understand
He's been watching you longer than anyone else in this room He told the truth and never denied it I
'm guessing
Don't you think it's Rei Uno who's selfish about Mr. Tani opening up on his own? The
ad testified
to that.
Matter After being deceived by you, I was deceived
.